I want to be the biggest movie star in
the world
and I need you guys to tell me how to do
it how do you then make sure that your
schedule Maps your ambition I'll give
you three tips on how to do it there's
the only way that you're gonna succeed
is if you're working the hardest out of
everybody in the world rise and shine
it's an espresso time what's up believe
nation it's evan my one word is believe
and I believe in you I believe you have
Michael Jordan level talent at something
and I want you to find it embrace it and
use it to make a difference so let's
start your day off right together grab
your coffee and sip on today's message
dedicate your life to your dream over to
you will smith also if you want to hear
what Will Smith and other successful
entrepreneurs have to say about building
confidence check out my 250 for
confidence series
I was excited about taking a shot the
fact that he was so strange you know as
an artist it was it was fun to get out
on that on that limb and hoping it
doesn't break under your feet every day
for the next 254 days I will send you a
30-second two five minute video for free
every morning to help you build
unstoppable confidence the link is in
the description
I think it was 94 or something like that
they were open to Planet Hollywood I
found myself in a room with Arnold
Schwarzenegger Bruce Willis and sly and
I was like oh my god I got these three
guys in the room and I was like okay I
want to be the biggest movie star in the
world and I need you guys to tell me how
to do it and Arnold Schwarzenegger he
said he said if your movie is only big
in America it doesn't matter you'll be a
movie star
only when you're a movie star in every
country in the world you have to travel
you have to go you have to meet the
people thanks for the tip fax son fax
that became the way that I started
looking at movies I wanted to be in
every country in the world in that part
of my career I refused to do anything
that wasn't in the best interest of the
goal I had set for myself and there's
probably a 12 year period of my life
where I did take a train I have a drink
where I didn't go out on the weekends
that I was so set on my goal it created
a serious circle of protection and an
elevation because I refused to do
anything that wasn't in my best interest
it's hugely important that if you have a
dream that you have to dedicate your
life to it and yeah every hour of every
day has to be dedicated to bring it into
fruition the things that you dream about
your schedule has to map to your
ambition what is in your calendar aka
the warp that you were doing on a daily
basis has to match to you being able to
accomplish your goals
I can't tell you how many entrepreneurs
I meet who talk a big game
who have big dreams who want to go off
and change the world which I love it's
amazing and then look at their calendar
I asked let me see your phone like load
your calendars show me what you're doing
on a weekly basis on a daily basis and
so few of the activities in your
calendar actually leading to you
accomplishing your big mission and
that's why you never get it done because
you're stuck in just dreaming mode
instead of actually being in doing mode
and listen I get it you might have a job
you might have a family you have lots of
other commitments I get it your people
are different stage
you're working towards building a better
plane it's awesome you want to quit your
job and go full-time great what are you
even doing enough in that zone in that
territory right like don't wait six
months before you can quit your job and
then start working on your business you
keep your job when you start working
right now you have to find time right
now you have to find time on a daily
basis in your calendar to do the work
that is going to allow your mission to
happen because otherwise it's just
motivation and you ever do anything with
it I went to Tony Robbins event in San
Diego San Jose San Jose la la it was in
LA unleash the power then I love Tony
we've done tons of content on Tony
worked his team on different promotions
as well and the thing that you get there
is a lot of people get really really
motivated and he likes that but the only
reason why he wants you to get motivated
is because he wants to lift you up
enough to give you the confidence and
the energy to then go and take action so
while a lot of people around me were
just getting motivated Wow RAAA is
amazing I'm sitting there thinking okay
if I want to apply this it has to go
into my calendar because what's in my
calendar gets done and whenever I put in
there has to lead to me achieving the
objective that I'm after where so many
people go just to get the motivational
hit and then you fall back down and you
go back to your old life when you go
home and so that's the frustration for
me too for people watching these videos
I want you to not just get inspired and
motivated and think that that is the
work watching this video does nothing
it's what you do afterwards that counts
watching this video does not count for
you building your business you have to
watch the video and take action do
something you know YouTube's goal is to
keep you on YouTube all day long I don't
want you on YouTube all day long I want
you to watch whatever you need to watch
to get into the mindset to get into the
zone to get the ideas the strategies yes
some motivation and also some tactics
and then execute go and do if you never
need to come back to my youtube channel
again after this awesome I love it and
if you need it every single day like I
do awesome I love it but for as much as
I consume I make a lot like I create a
lot and that's where I need you to move
from that zone of thinking like watching
his videos actually doing something it's
not it's planning it's mindset it's
great but you have to still then take
action
so how do you do it how do you then make
sure that your schedule maps to your
ambition I'll give you three tips on how
to do it one is scheduled one hour a day
one hour day towards moving towards your
big ambition whatever that is if you're
in a business you already have a
business you really have a team of
employees awesome one hour a day ideally
the first day in the morning when you
get in so it's easier to protect that
time and block it from being you know
managing other people's distractions and
their what they want for you but one
hour a day
I call it CEO time and a minimum focused
on projects that will move your business
forward if you don't have a business yet
you don't have a team yet it's still
spending time every day if you're still
moonlighting you still got a company
going on you're still spending one hour
a day building the business when you've
set a goal for yourself it's important
that you do it when you put in your
calendar you have to do it and when you
have other things that get in the way
and then you still find a way to do it
that's how you build self-respect when I
went to Boston I got there 3:00 in the
morning and was tired I wanted to sleep
but I told myself I was gonna do half an
hour of cardio everyday and they stayed
up from 3:00 to 3:30 to do the cardio
that may not make a lot of logical sense
but it builds my self-respect it builds
my self-identity
that when I say I'm gonna do something I
do it and even though I didn't have a
lot of sleep and the next day I was
tired for the whole day I felt great
about myself and continue to feel great
about myself because it's easy to do it
when it's easy it's easy to spend an
hour on your business when you have an
entire Sunday open no responsibilities
no family members nothing it's easy to
spend an hour but it's hard to spend the
hour when you've got a lot of stuff
happening you've got lots of
distractions lots of chaos lots of
responsibilities and you still find the
time that's when you can feel great
about yourself if you let yourself off
the hook and say it's okay I don't need
to do it you slowly eat away at your
self-respect
whoever you say I'm gonna make this
happen I commit it to myself that
doesn't get this goal done and then you
do it that's when you start building up
your self-respect so super important
that once you say you're gonna do
something you follow through and do it
not about the results but about the
action so one hour per day one hour per
day focused on help when you make your
mission come true number two is create
your own 254
so the 254 is a new series I created my
first ones around confidence where every
day I talked about the beginning every
day for the next 254 days I send you a
video on your confidence I'm helping you
build unstoppable confidence because if
you are around confident people every
day
for the next 254 days you will become
more confident and so whatever your
dream is whatever your mission is if you
are around people who are doing that
every day you will become like that
the fastest way to learn Japanese is go
to Japan the fastest way to become a
writer is to be around other great
writers and you may not have access to
Stephen King and all these other great
writers who you might look up to but if
they're in your inbox every day if
you're watching them on a video every
day not to spend the whole day with them
not to spend an entire day watching
their videos and then nothing for the
next month every day create your own
2:54 my 2:54 is thirty Seconds to
five-minute video every single day just
to just to get your mind set just to
trigger it just a trigger success in
that field whatever it is that you want
to do create your own version of it I'm
gonna be making more but it cost me
10,000 bucks
each time to make one so bear with me
I'm working my way through them I don't
know what you're not gonna do next is
lots of requests and demands but like
but but don't wait for me like make your
own make your own 2:54 for every day for
the next 254 days you wake up and you
watch a quick video from somebody who
you really respect is doing the thing
that you want to do if you did that
every day your mindset would shift your
habits would shift your belief system
would improve you would grow stronger
you would become more focused you'd be
more dedicated to your mission so create
you on to 54 and number 3 is the 80/20
around doing vs. planning I think a lot
of people are just stuck in planning
mode so that hour that you spending
every day you want 80% of it to be on
doing and only 20% max to be on planning
where I think most people have a flipped
you spend that hour a day in planning
mode like watching the video that's
planning consuming is planning thinking
is just planning right it's helpful you
need it you can't just do all day long
without any kind of plan but planning is
less than 20% really of the of the time
that you should be spent doing something
you need to spend at least 80% of that
hour every single day on creating on
making on sharing so whether that's
sending emails out making Instagram
videos making a YouTube video calling on
clients going to a trade show making
partnerships going door to door trying
to find collaborations working on hiring
somebody for your team improving the
graphic design for your business and
your website like whatever the thing is
you're making something
it's something's gonna be put out it's
helping fuel the growth not just
thinking tinkering researching watching
it's important but if you spend 80% of
your time in research mode and 20% of
your time or less actually doing your
business won't get anywhere so adjust it
adjust the 80/20 rule 80% at least doing
20% thinking planning now I've got a
really special bonus clip that I think
you're gonna enjoy but before that I
want to know you're chasing this big
dream you've got this big mission what's
a single biggest shift that has to
happen in your life and your habits and
your responsibilities that you're gonna
take ownership of and start to change in
order to start to make that life that
you want happen leaving the comments
below I'm looking forward to hearing
what you have to say thank you guys so
much for watching I believe in you I
hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso and enjoy the
bonus clip
[Applause]
[Music]
I basically talked to all of my friends
all the time about acting and I love to
give people like inspirational talks so
I would say you have to really really
know that that's what you want to do and
you can't like change your mind later
because it's not gonna happen overnight
and you really just need to really be
dedicated about it and really like
decide right now that that's what you're
gonna do for the rest of your life
because the only way that you're gonna
succeed is if you're working the hardest
out of everybody in the world because
there's 300 other people actually
millions of other people that are trying
to do the same exact thing that you're
doing right now that's what I would say
so it's all about hard work it's all
about hard work and dedication it's just
you have to want it more than everyone
else don't do it because you're trying
to get your followers up know what I
mean
like if you're not really with the cause
you're not going to dedicate yourself a
thousand percent don't do it like when
you talk about Jim Brown and Bill
Russell those guys they dedicated
themselves a thousand percent we didn't
have Twitter back then and you're
following are they dedicated themselves
a thousand percent so if you're not
going to dedicate yourself a thousand
percent and if you're not going to do it
when the cameras are off don't do it
to realizes don't believe everything you
see in movies and read in books you know
there is no way both my wife who worked
for Steve directly I work for Steve
could do that for 10 years if there
wasn't some amazing stuff that came out
of it it wasn't like we were getting
whipped every day or nothing to do with
that we were dedicated we were
passionate he was passionate he wanted
the best for the company for the
products for our customers and when
you're in that there's a creative
tension and he emotionally would show
that passion sometimes sometimes it was
oh my god this is the best thing ever
you know you hear about the negatives
but you don't hear about all the
positives and all the great things he
did for use it did for the individual as
well as the company and all that stuff
so it was always a balance and those bad
days we're not all very often but they
did happen because typically yeah you
might have made a mistake don't do that
again or we weren't thinking about it
right or somebody was falling down on
the job or whatever the case may be
that's when it came out is when someone
didn't show respect for the mission they
were on when you didn't show respect for
the rest of your teammates and for the
thing we're trying to build that's when
there was a problem not when we were
falling when we fail when we tried
really hard and if we showed we tried
really hard then that was just an option
just like we the iPod phone was a
failure no one got killed over that it
was more just a you know okay we tried
our best we move on we tried our best we
move on it's when you were when you
didn't do what was right and you failed
from a because you didn't put your heart
and soul into it and you let the team
down that's when there was a problem and
that's what people need to realize it
was very balanced and he was very much
human passionate and he was very helpful
and all kinds of stuff but yes he did
have his bad days but not usually for
without reason raise your standard Apple
at the cool
it's core value is that we believe that
people with passion can change the way
people not one drop of myself work
depends on your that's something sue me
I don't ever give up I'd have to be dead
or completely incapacitated hey believe
nation if you want to see my all-time
favorite top ten roses success I have a
very special secret video for you these
are the individual clips that I have
personally learned the most from and
applied to my life and my business check
the link the description for details